good afternoon everyone my name is
adrian dicks i'm bc's minister of health
to my right is dr bonnie henry bc's
provincial health officer this our kovid
19
briefing for thursday march the 10th
2022
dr henry and i are honored to be here on
the territory of the quang and speaking
people of the sangees and the esquimalt
first nations
dr henry will be referring to a
powerpoint which will be available on
social media and on government websites
including the bccdc and
gov.bc.ca shortly and with that it's my
honor to introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
today we're going to walk through
where we are in the pandemic and talk
about
where we're going next
to start with where we are today we are
progressing well and we're going in the
right direction and it really is thanks
to people in british columbia stepping
up and doing what we needed to do we now
have
over 55 percent of children 5 to 11 who
have been vaccinated 90 over 90 percent
of british columbians 12 and over have
received their first dose of vaccine
sorry two doses of vaccine and
about 56 percent of people have received
that important booster dose
our hospitalizations continue to
decrease which is also really good news
if we look at it in terms of
our epidemic curve we see that our cases
of lab confirmed cases have come down
dramatically in the last few weeks but
really importantly our hospitalizations
have also
decreased and the number of people in
critical care has decreased
this is encouraging because as
transmission goes down so the risks to
all of us go down in the community our
approach has always been to only have
the minimal necessary restrictions to
keep people safe and to prevent the
transmission particularly to those who
are more susceptible to severe illness
with covet 19 it is finding that balance
i am incredibly grateful to the millions
of people throughout our province for
your willingness and support in adopting
our covet 19 safety measures
your efforts combined with these high
vaccination rates have saved countless
lives
together we've done what is right at the
right time
and now we're in a place we where we can
once again adjust our approach
if we look at our hospitalization rates
another important measure of course is
by age
and we know that it continues to be our
elders and seniors across our
communities who are more at risk of
severe illness and hospitalization and
thankfully that continues to come down
as well
we have a number of different
surveillance measures that we have been
following closely one of them of course
is our wastewater surveillance and we
see a consistent decrease in low levels
of virus now being detected in
wastewater and so that is also another
important measure that helps us
understand where we are in terms of risk
in our communities
if we compare where we are compared to
other jurisdictions across the country
we see that we have had a lower peak and
a slower peak than many other places and
our hospital admissions specifically
have decreased by about 34 percent in
the last month to less than 100 new
admissions each day
we also know that
with the
omicron variant that has come into play
in the last few months here in british
columbia that admissions to hospital
with covet have decreased more than
people who have been detected with kobu
and if we can the same comparisons with
other jurisdictions around the world we
see that the the actions that we have
taken here in british columbia and that
people have stepped up and been
vaccinated has meant that we have fared
well compared to many other
jurisdictions in the country
if we look at our hospitalizations
compared to the modeling that we've been
following over the last few months in
particular we see that we've tracked
along where we've expected to be
with the rate of vaccination and
immunity that we have in our community
and with people taking those measures
that we put in place to prevent
transmission and we expect that to
continue as we are in a good place today
we are one of the most vaccinated
jurisdictions in the world and that
layer that protection that we get
through vaccination and that immunity
that we have across our communities has
meant that we have been resilient in
getting through the omicron wave it has
protected so many people and yes the
risk of infection with the omicron and
the protection that we get from two
doses of vaccine is less than with some
of the other variants but we have seen
very strong protection against severe
illness and we do know that people with
two doses of vaccine are less likely to
get
infected themselves and less likely to
transmit to others and that increases
the protection that we see with three
doses with that booster dose bumps it up
to over 60 percent protection against
any infection and that again protects
against transmission to others we also
on this slide have put in
some of the additional immunity that we
have in our community from people who
have been
infected particularly recently with
omicron to give you a sense of the small
proportion that is also an increase of
protection that we have of immunity
across our communities we know that
people who have two doses of vaccine on
board who got infected with omicron most
of whom thankfully had a relatively mild
illness
have a good strong booster effect from
that infection as well so all of this
means that the level of immunity that we
have across bc right now means that we
can take some of the tools that we have
been using consistently and repeatedly
and relax some of these
measures the most uh just to to follow
up on our
whole genome sequencing that we've been
doing we can see the red is when omicron
came on board we are starting to see
some geographic changes in
variants they're all considered omicron
but as we see as it replicates it can
change slightly and we've seen the ba1
which is the lighter red and ba 1.1
which has
increased in the the recent weeks and a
little bit of an increase in the ba2
that is one that we've been watching
carefully around the world because it
does seem to have even increased
infectiousness
but so far we're not seeing a rapid
growth in that and as numbers of cases
have come down
the while the percentage is going up the
absolute number of people with ba2 is
actually going down as well and it tells
us again that as rates of transmission
go down we're all protected a little
better
so what does that mean for us now
with the science and our data top of
mind it clearly shows that our risks now
are much lower they're not zero and
we're not fully out of this yet but i
feel confident that we can safely make
some further changes
for many months now we've had a number
of tools in our toolkit that have helped
us to get to this point
we've had to use all of them all of the
time
and we are now transitioning to using
some of our available tools some of the
time because we are in a lower risk
place
as of 1201 tomorrow so not 11 59 1201
march 11th
the following changes to the provincial
health officer ordinance and guidelines
will come into effect
firstly i will be will be repealing the
face covering order
um the order restricting
overnight child and youth camps will be
lifted and that's
one that will be of particular interest
to some parents
in particular and camp operators this
was the order that required that a
specific coveted safety plan plan be in
place and be approved by mhos so we can
now start to plan for having summer
camps for children and youth
we are going to restore the visitation
policies that we had in long-term care
prior to the additional measures that we
put in place for omicron
so that means that starting a week from
tomorrow on
march 18th
we'll be
restoring a long-term care visitation
and the goal will be to increase
visitation and opportunities for
connection between residents and
families while continuing to protect
those we know are most vulnerable to
serious illness
we know that there are some challenges
across the board but including in
long-term care with things like staff
shortages and operators may need to
manage visitation based on the situation
with each individual care home so what
i'm asking for is patients over the
coming week all of the care home
operators will communicate with families
around their plans for resuming broader
social visitation and in some cases
depending on the individual situation
they this may mean planning visits in
advance or spacing them out because of
need
the the requirements for being fully
vaccinated will continue to be in place
as will testing with rapid tests on
entry to
long-term care
so just to to talk a little bit more
about repealing the face coverings order
what this means is that masks will no
longer
be mandatory in those broad ranges of
indoor environments that this order sets
out
however some settings will still require
that you wear a mask for example for
healthcare settings physicians offices
patients contact areas but most low-risk
locations it will now be an option and
no longer a necessity
critical to success though as we move
through this transition phase is for
everybody to move at your own pace
we have learned learned and we we know
now a lot more about mass than we did a
few years ago they are both a layer of
protection for ourselves and importantly
a layer of protection for those around
us
so the wild mass are no longer required
or mandated under an order as of
tomorrow
some people in some locations
will and continue to use mass personally
or in their business
and that's okay we need to support that
we need to recognize that we all have
our own risks and our own
vulnerabilities and particularly if you
are older if you're immune compromised
you may still wear a mask in some
locations especially if you're inside or
around a large number of people that you
don't know
if you've not yet had your booster or
your children are not yet vaccinated
then masks continue to be a very
important protective layer that you may
want to continue to use especially in
larger crowds and indoors
if we
in part of the mask order was that
coveted safety plans needed to include
masking in common areas of workplaces
and that is no longer an order but in
many workplaces mass will still be
required they just will no longer be
mandated in those areas
mass continue to be encouraged in some
of those settings where we have to get
close to other people and we can't
necessarily avoid it in things like
public transit and on bc ferries
but they're no longer as i said mandated
under an order
the other important sectors that this
affects of course are child care and
early childhood education and our k-12
sector so child care guidelines are
we're going to be revising them we're in
the process of revising them with our
child care and early childhood educator
stakeholders and they will be updated to
reflect on the different risk levels and
and the use of masks
and the k to 12 school guidelines are
being revised as well
and this means that masks will no longer
be required in all settings in schools
once children and staff return from
spring break so we recognize that spring
break is slightly different in the 60
school districts across the province
some
a good portion start tomorrow
and a number start the end of next week
and so what we have done is made sure
that all of the revisions in the
guidance will come into play when you
return from spring break at whenever
that is for each school district and if
you're not sure which school district it
is there'll be a link to that on the
website with the order
additionally
those workplaces that are federally
regulated will need to continue to
follow federal health orders and
guidelines around workplaces
so what's ahead in addition to the
changes in orders and guidance for today
that start soon we intend to remove
additional orders in another four weeks
effective friday april 8th and that is
of course assuming that our
conditions continue to improve
these will include the bc vaccine card
will no longer be required in those
indoor settings and higher risk settings
and events
and
the post
businesses will transition from the
workplace safety order which requires
covet 19 specific safety plans to the
previous plans that we had in place last
summer the communicable disease plans so
those will be specific to each industry
or business
uh in addition we're going to be
repealing the an order that requires
post-secondary students who live in
residence to be vaccinated
and workplaces will transition back to
this requirement rather than having the
broader communicable disease plans in
place oops
sorry
so those are are going to be effective
on april 8th as we said we're going to
take a balanced and
transition approach over the next few
weeks
i do also want to talk about the
regulated health professionals order as
you know earlier this week we published
the current part of the order that
requires regulated health professionals
to report to their college their
vaccination stages by the end of march
and this has been a change in how we're
approaching this order given the
situation that we're in right now but
also given our ongoing consultation with
the various colleges that are affected
so we want to ensure that
colleges had the ability to collect that
information from registrants and to do
it in a way that was confidential
as well as
making sure that we had the ability to
provide options to people in the
regulated health professions
including the new protein subunit
vaccines like novovax and there has been
a delay in our receipt of novovax we had
expected it to be
in the province by last week and it
looks like now we may not receive it
until
either the third or last week of march
so i think that's a very important
consideration
both for those
people who already have been affected by
orders in their workplaces but also
for the regulated health professions
we are taking then a measured approach
based on the risk and impact with each
individual college as we go forward
so that means
we will have in place
a measure for informed consent so that
people can understand
the
that there'll be disclosure to clients
or patients of vaccination status for
some of the regulated health professions
and for others there may be additional
measures that we need in place so yes
this is different from our original
vision which would be
people not being able to practice
if they
if they were not vaccinated by march
24th
we've been working through the specifics
with each individual college and based
on the risks within each profession uh
there will be a component of public
reporting as i said and then we will
continue to take additional measures as
needed
considering the important impact on
patients on communities from each
individual provider
i do want to say as well that our aim is
to be consistent with the health care
worker order that we already have in
place that has been so important in
supporting us particularly through the
the delta and omicron waves in our
healthcare sector in health authorities
and hospitals in the community
it is an important measure that ensures
we have continued high level of immunity
in our healthcare sector
as we go through this transition phase
and prepare for what comes next in terms
of sars co v2 because this virus is
still with us we are not yet at the
place where we understand it enough and
we know the patterns and the changes
that this virus will undergo
and to be able to call it endemic but we
are learning to live with it in a more
sustainable way at the same time as
supporting people to recover from the
measures that we've been through for the
last two years
so really while we are able to announce
these changes today it's very important
that we continue to follow our safety
basics as much as possible
to keep covet 19 low and slow
in particular i continue to strongly
urge you to ensure everyone in your
family is vaccinated and have your
booster if you have not already done so
these are layers that are important for
us to be using all the time
but we are in a transition phase we need
to be ready and prepared for what the
virus may bring next and there are many
different scenarios that we are working
through to make sure we understand the
potential
particularly
as we go into the fall but right now the
important things all of us need to do
are monitor ourselves for symptoms
making sure we stay home if we're
feeling unwell get tested and we now
have uh increasing access to rapid
antigen tests to help support you in
making those decisions
washing our hands regularly staying home
if we're not well getting boosted and
ensuring
we get vaccinated and importantly as we
have done through this whole pandemic we
need to respect people's comfort levels
and their own risk levels and we've
talked about this
in a number of different ways we all
have our own risk and we may not be
aware of the risks of those around us we
need to be respectful about mask wearing
we need to be respectful about people's
choices to keep their gatherings small
or to stay outside rather than inside
and while today is another really
positive step forward we have to be
ready to bring some tools back if
necessary depending on the situation as
it changes
we are also paying a lot of attention
about what's going to happen next it's
become clear to us that kovit is going
to be with us that cyrus v2 this virus
will be circulating in our communities
for time to come and it means that we
have to add it as another virus that we
need to pay attention to and manage in
an ongoing basis along with the other
serious respiratory illnesses like
influenza and rsv
and so that is the the
position that we're taking that we're
looking at through what are the
surveillance mechanisms what do we need
to monitor over time to help us
understand the impact on our communities
when we're starting to see surges if the
virus is changing what's the impact on
hospitals and
in our health care system so we are
continuing to do population level
sentinel surveillance and we'll be
integrating it with our influenza and
rrsv surveillance over the coming
months
we'll continue to do facility-based
monitoring and acute care and long-term
care
we have systematic early warning sim
signals through things like our
wastewater surveillance which will be
expanding to to more communities and to
include more pathogens more bugs
we'll also be doing systematic targeted
serological surveillance we've done that
at periodic times where we've tested
samples of blood
from people in the community by age to
determine levels of immunity and that's
one of the reasons why we could present
the data that i showed earlier
and we'll continue with our whole genome
sequencing to understand how this virus
is changing over time
i recognize the changes we're announcing
today will make some people very
uncomfortable it has been a long and
trying two years
our masks and other safety layers have
provided a level of comfort and
protection for all of us and it's why
it's important for everybody to move at
our own pace
i want to assure you that i feel
confident about what we are doing and
that we are in a place to do this now
these decisions are grounded in science
and in the data that we have about
what's happening in our communities for
where we are right now
we're able to make these changes and the
ones that are ahead for two very
important reasons
first because people in british columbia
have stepped up and protected themselves
and their families by getting vaccinated
and second because people have followed
these safety measures we've put in place
when it was necessary to do so
the need for these every single one of
these particular layers of protection
has dropped below the threshold where we
need to have an order for them to be in
place
that means we can move from a mandated
approach to an empowered self-management
approach we've all learned how to wear
masks and when it's important we've
learned about the importance of staying
away from others if we're feeling unwell
and when to get a test these are all
things that we will need to continue to
have to manage in ourselves
it's a good place for us to be
and i'm optimistic that we'll be able to
continue this path at least for the
spring and summer months ahead we have
that high level of immunity and
understanding right now
but we need to continue to do this with
respect for each other and for our own
decisions whether it's wearing a mask
[Music]
whether it's gathering outside whether
it's taking those same cautious approach
that have gotten you through this far
and we need to continue to do this with
compassion for each other and with
kindness
thank you
thank you
dr henry today i'll provide an update to
hopefully a shorter update to give more
lots of opportunity for members of the
media to ask
to ask questions
an update on rapid tests and surgical
renewal but
first i want to express
my thanks to british columbians for
their significant efforts and
willingness to make sacrifices to keep
themselves
their loved ones and our most vulnerable
citizens safe
and special appreciation as minister of
health
to health care workers everywhere in bc
and all they have contributed at every
level in home care and home support the
people who provide
food and clean our hospitals and our
long-term care facilities our health
sciences professionals
our ambulance paramedics our doctors our
nurses our health care workers our care
aides
they have been throughout this pandemic
heroes to all of us and to me
i want to express my appreciation for
all that they've done
and i'm proud that we have a health care
system
180 000 strong 50 000 in long-term care
130 000 in the main health care system
all all of whom every one of whom
is vaccinated how we have health care
workers who are determined and committed
to supporting all of us in a challenging
time
we have today we're going to have today
when the numbers are announced less than
400 people in acute care that's 400
people on top of all the other people
who need health care every day there are
today 9 400 people in our acute care
facilities and of course people dealing
with challenges in long-term care
and i must say that i was particularly
happy
with the proposals that dr henry has
made and that will be put in place to
allow broader visitation and long-term
care again for
long-term care residents to have
multiple
visitors
all vaccinated
all tested
and all there to provide love and caring
and engagement and support to people who
live in long-term care to ensure that
all what we're doing what we want
long-term care to do which is not just
to be a place to support people who have
significant health challenges but also a
place
where people despite those health
challenges have the freedom to live and
express themselves in their lives
i wanted to just bring an update then on
the number of rapid tests in bc
as of march 9th bc has received 35
million three hundred forty six thousand
six hundred fifty eight rapid tests
we continue to prepare for the arrival
of tests at approximately three million
per week over the coming weeks
twenty six million forty eight thousand
two hundred eighty two tests have been
deployed to key strategic areas i've
described those at length and future
briefings but i would be happy to
describe them to members of the media
who seek that information again
the total number of tests distributed
through all our distribution channels
across bc since our last briefing that
was march first is four million one
hundred forty seven thousand five
hundred and fifteen
as previously previously noted just over
a half a million tests or five hundred
and eighty fifty eight thousand of our
inventory are not suitable for
deployment for personal use and are
being used at the discretion of medical
health officers in the appropriate
settings
that leaves a current inventory of eight
million seven hundred forty two thousand
eight hundred tests suitable for
self-administered use
to date 4.4 million tests have been
distributed to k-12 schools across the
province 2.1 million tests have been
distributed to post-secondary
institutions and 5.3 million tests have
been sent
to pharmacies as announced last week
these tests are for british columbians
aged 60 and older to pick up a kit
containing five tests at participating
pharmacies this age group is a priority
because the evidence indicates that they
are a more serious risk of serious
consequences should they become infected
if they become symptomatic the test will
allow them to determine
if they may have profit 19 so that they
can take the actions that are required
and as of this morning 1 million 323
430 tests have been dispensed by 1
287 pharmacies and say that as of
tomorrow
we will be lowering the age the age
category for access to tests tomorrow to
those 50 to 59 so those will start to be
available for those 50 age 50 to 59
starting tomorrow and for more
information on accessing test kits
british columbians can visit
bcpharmacy.ca and i want to express my
appreciation to pharmacists across
british columbia for all of their work
both in our vaccination program in the
influenza vaccination program and of
course in the deployment of rapid tests
increased test availability means that
more members of the general population
will be able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness and to take action to limit
transmission to their family
friends and work including those at
higher risk
i want to also provide an update to our
surgical renewal
initiative
health authorities report that as of in
the week of february 6th to the 12th
6442 surgeries were completed
in
nbc
and that's a significant number we also
wanted to say that from february 27 to
march 5th the most recent week
obviously before us health authorities
postponed 64 non-urgent scheduled
surgeries that number continues to
decline that's one in fraser health 62
in interior health and one in vancouver
coastal health no surgeries were
postponed
[Music]
just wait for the bells
no surgeries were postponed in the
vancouver island health authority or the
northern health authority or the
provincial health services authority
cumulatively from september 5th 2021 to
march 5th
uh 20 march 5th 2022 regional surge
surges of kova 19 and factors including
severe weather patterns have caused 8098
surgical post moments i would note that
more than half of those postponements
now have received their surgery more
than half which is an exceptional
achievement and we will continue over
the coming weeks to book
surgeries to get people the surgeries
they need our whole health care system
is committed to that and i am committed
to that personally but i know our
outstanding surgeons and nurses and
healthcare workers who are involved in
this are committed to it and i think
it's significant to say
that that those rebooking of surgeries i
think speaks of the work that all of us
have done that in the moments that
mattered most in the omicron wave we
each made the difference essential to
stopping the rapid spread of coven and
in doing so in reducing hospitalizations
from 1059 on january the 31st to 388
today
we've had a major impact on our
healthcare system in a positive way
it means now that we can rebook
surgeries but our work is not done as dr
henry has said
the covid19 virus
and the kovid 19 pandemic will continue
to challenge us
the measures taken today are a positive
step and they reflect where we stand
today
but we are always humble
for a virus which lives to transmit
and finds different ways to transmit
and humble towards the people of bc
who have in very challenging ways and in
difficult ways in ways that we could not
have imagined when we formed our own
emergency
group to deal with the covet 19 pandemic
in january of of 2020 or two years ago
tomorrow when the declaration of a
pandemic was made
the sacrifices that people have made and
the things they've done it to for one
another and the kindness they have
demonstrated to one another has been i
think something that all british
colombians can take pride in
there will be more tests ahead there
will and i know we're prepared to stand
together in these important moments
stand together and support one another
to be careful yes to be safe yes and
also to be kind and i think that is if
there are lessons on this day it's that
the things that have allowed us to
respond to the pandemic in the past are
still with us which is a great province
great people
and outstanding healthcare workers
everywhere in bc and with that honorable
i was about to say honorable speaker how
about that i'm in the building i won't
say that i won't say that
but with that with that all of you we're
happy to take your question
thank you a reminder to media on the
line please press star one to enter the
queue you will be limited to one
question and one follow-up our first
question comes from the room today
richard sussman global news
some jurisdictions have decided to allow
transit to keep masking for longer
periods of time you haven't done that
here what's the guidance to bc transit
and translink what do you say to those
who are immunocompromised at highest
risk
who are now going to be worried just to
walk into a grocery store or to complete
the essentials of their life considering
that others around them may not be
wearing their masks yeah you know i know
that this is going to be a challenging
time for for people who are feeling very
much at risk and have taken those
precautions over this last two years
just to say that we can look at what's
happening in terms of transmission
across our communities and as that goes
down we're all a little safer and those
environments where we were requiring to
have multiple different layers of
protection we no longer need all of
those layers to be mandated all of the
time so yes i'll continue to wear my
mask if i'm on public transit and i
would encourage others to do so too we
know it protects us but it's also a sign
of respect and protect for other
protection for others
but we also need to be clear that things
like grocery stores are not the highest
risk environments when we go in them so
it's a matter of time and space and how
close we are to people so let's continue
to be respectful recognize that some
people will need to continue to wear
masks and it'll be important for them
and that we should keep a respectful
distance for people um so that we're not
crowding them in places like grocery
stores and other essential places but i
think we're in a good place now it's not
out of the woods by all means and i
would encourage people to assess their
own risk and the the risk of those
around them as we go through this next
few weeks and we hopefully will continue
to see the risk go away the other part i
think that's really important is the
vaccination of so many people and the
immunity that we have in our community
now means that that risk is down quite a
lot so um
it's going to take some time to build
that confidence again to go out to those
places and i encourage people to take
your own time and wear your own mask
as long as you feel comfortable doing
that
richard you have a follow-up just on
that briefly i'm trying to understand if
something like transit or bc fairies can
put in a mask mandate still yes
absolutely um workplaces some places may
uh may feel that it's important for
their workers to be
protected for various reasons and they
can
require mask wearing they can require
the vaccine card in certain settings but
they need to do their own diligence
about what that means and how that will
impact their workplace
the next question comes from justine
hunter globe and mail
hi thank you um dr henry i understand
that you've changed the plan but i'm
just not clear and i'm hoping you can
spell this out for me have you dropped
the requirement for all regulated
healthcare professionals to be
vaccinated in order to work in bc uh
no not entirely what we've done is taken
a look at the the multiple different
colleges in different regulated health
professionals and we're taking a more
nuanced risk based approach for some
that will mean that you must be
vaccinated to practice in certain
settings
but we're doing that on a more
tailored basis to each of the regulated
health professions and in a step-wise
way and we have the advantage right now
of being in a place where we can take
the time to work through it individually
with the colleges and with individual
registrants in each college and as i
mentioned i wanted to ensure that we had
options available and just to be clear
these options like novavax and the
metacago the protein subunit vaccines
are available for other workers who are
in
who have
stepped away from work so other
healthcare workers
in our public system who are ready to be
vaccinated i encourage you to call the
number and and book a dose of novovax it
should be in in the next few weeks
i will commit to the one part that we
have been working with the colleges on
is ensuring that there is a a way
for individual patients or clients to be
informed and to have informed consent
about their services that are being
provided to them
justine do you have a follow-up
i do thank you dr henry again to you
you've talked throughout the pandemic
about using science and data to guide
public health decisions i'm wondering uh
your thoughts on one of the province's
chief medical officers
citing as evidence uh to guide these
decisions a paper that argues the risks
and harms of punitive public health
strategies
may outweigh the benefits
yeah so um that that paper as you know
is a is an opinion piece that was uh
published on the social sciences uh
network and it is something that reminds
us that there are consequences to the
measures that we put in place and it is
really important to take those into
account
we have always tried to balance the
risks and benefits of each measure that
we've put in place and to do it in a way
that's thoughtful and i think we've done
that in bc
from very early on i've been uh i've we
have a group that has been working on
measuring the unintended consequences
we've done things like uh the the kovitz
speak survey to help understand the
impacts both of the measures that we put
in place to manage covet and the effects
of the virus and the pandemic itself so
those are very important considerations
and that's why we have limited where we
have the bc vaccine card in effect for
example where we've limited the mandates
and the orders to try and put the least
restrictive means in place as much as
possible and where we've had vaccine
mandates focusing on those highest risk
settings like health care settings so i
think it is
in my opinion a slightly biased opinion
piece but those are all very important
considerations that we have looked at
and we need to continue to monitor and
to take into account as we put in or
remove the restrictions that we've seen
in place here
next question comes from rob shaw check
news
oh hi um just um
i just wanted dr henry if you could
compare
where we were june 29th of last year
when we left mass uh the first time to
where we are now we had a lower
vaccination rate i think it was 32
percent double dose we're at 91
percent now we had 29 cases that day
back then we're at 270 something now
you've mentioned the higher vaccination
rate but what makes it different those
two times given that we had to bring
masks back a few weeks later in august
versus where we are now when we lift
them this time
yeah i think the philosophy of where we
are the trajectory is the same in that
you use
the least amount of tools that are
needed
by a mandate so by an order
at the times when you can so as cases
were coming down vaccination rates were
high
the viruses strains that we were dealing
with at the time where the vaccination
the two doses was very protective for
people and we saw cases come down
and you know we were optimistic that
that might be
the the point where we would no longer
need to put measures in place
that required things like masking and
other
things that we put in place and what
happened was we were faced with yet
another strain another variant of
concern that caused rapidly increasing
cases so all of those tools became
important again and that's where the
importance of the bc vaccine card came
into play making sure that we did have
vaccine available and as you remember at
that time younger children were not yet
eligible for vaccinations so under 17
making sure that people did get their
second dose
boosting up the rates of immunization in
in those younger age groups where it was
still lagging so it was important um and
as we saw the change in the virus and
the patterns of transmission and who was
getting sick we needed to add additional
tools so we're at a place now where we
have a much higher level of community
immunity
primarily from vaccination and a little
bit from people who've been
had recent infections and we're seeing
that that means cases are decreasing and
the cases that are occurring are mostly
milder and so we need a new set of tools
to help us get through this period and
we no longer need to have
all of the measures all of the time by
by way of an order so i think in some
ways we're in a very similar situation
if we start to see uh you know this is
one of the things that we've been
working through with uh colleagues
around the world um you know what's
going to happen next
we think that there's very likely to
continue to be strong protection from
our cell-mediated immunity against this
virus no matter how much it mutates in
its spike protein for example
so but that means that we may see with
similar things to what we saw with
omicron where infectiousness
because the virus is trying to find ways
to to infect more people so there may be
changes that mean that we'll have to go
back to having mask wearing in certain
situations or capacity limits in certain
situations but i think we're in a good
place right now
where we don't need that for this period
of time
rob do you have a follow-up
sure i guess just to follow
up what you just said there there might
be situations where we bring back some
tools like
masks or capacity limits to could you
foresee the vaccine card being
brought back if things
change and also
do you expect to jump in cases or
hospitalization or icu rates um in the
short term as these masks come off and
if so as we're watching these what's
kind of an acceptable or
understood to be kind of results of
maybe this that we shouldn't panic about
if we see it yeah we may see a slight
increase in cases but i don't expect to
see a jump in you know some of the
modeling that helps us understand that
the potential impacts shows that it's
unlikely we may see a slight increase or
a leveling off or you know a decrease in
the decrease
but it's unlikely that we're going to
see a spike right now
because of the high level of immunity
that we have um that's why i'm i'm
looking really towards
towards the fall in our respiratory
season because that's where the higher
risk potential is and there may be other
things that we'll need to put in place
so it'll depend you know i talked about
an optimistic scenario is a virus that
is not that much more
a strain that's not that much more
transmissible and it doesn't cause more
severe disease but a pessimistic model
might be a virus strain that is
able to evade immunity and
cause more severe disease in which case
we may have to bring back some of those
additional measures or we may have to
have a new vaccine program
you know i suspect we may need a
targeted vaccine program depending on
who's getting infected so it may be an
additional dose for
our elders seniors people in long-term
care
so those are the things that we don't
yet know
but that we need to have
measures in place to be able to monitor
for and to have those tools that we all
now know how to use and be prepared to
to bring them back if we need to
next question bender sagin ctv
hello there um i'm just wondering i
heard you speak about the high level of
vaccinate vaccination here in bc
and i'm sure other people are wondering
as well uh why are we waiting four weeks
to remove the vaccine passport when we
see other provinces have already removed
it or are removing it weeks sooner
yeah so
it's been used in different ways in
different provinces so we had a very
limited uh areas where our the the bc
vaccine card was being used in those
highest risk settings and most of those
settings so if we think about a bar
restaurant
a nightclub an event
are settings where at least some of the
time we don't wear masks and so we need
to mitigate the risk of transmission in
those settings while we still have
reasonably high transmission in our
communities right now so we are taking
this in a stepwised and measured way
so that as people get used to being out
and about without masks on in some
settings
we still have the confidence to go to
some of these higher risk indoor
settings as well so it is a transition
period where we're going to be watching
carefully to make sure we're not seeing
the spike in cases and to ensure that we
do this in a way that supports people
who are feeling still very vulnerable at
this point in time
bender do you have a follow-up
i do and i know you've spoke about this
a couple of times but i'm just wondering
for the healthcare workers who were
terminated because they were subject to
a mandate and didn't get vaccinated
does that mandate still apply to them
and also uh the tone of this press
conference seems to be one of a farewell
for now uh what do you expect in terms
of updates uh for the public going
forward
i'm going to run away for a long time no
the uh
in in terms of the the healthcare worker
mandate yes that remains in effect it's
really important and i i mentioned this
that we have that baseline level of
immunity and we've seen how important
immunization in our health care sector
is so what we are working on in
with
the ministry and with our
the colleges and and the healthcare
professions and the health authorities
is an ongoing policy that includes covet
immunization but other immunizations
that are important for us in terms of
protecting healthcare resources so our
health
ourselves as well as making sure that
we're doing everything we can to prevent
transmission of of communicable diseases
vaccine preventable diseases in our
health care system
in terms of what we're doing yes we're
not going to have an official media
briefing for the next couple of weeks
but we will before
to make sure that we have an update
before
april 8th
to give
people
so that we are monitoring what we're
doing we'll be continuing with our daily
issues briefs with the the basic
information in the dashboard
for the next few weeks up until april
and then we'll be transitioning to a
weekly surveillance report after that
and just to express uh my appreciation
as you know uh
across the province uh when the vaccine
vaccination uh proof of vaccination
requirement was in place in
the public health care system that's 180
000 workers including all those workers
in long-term care
our healthcare workers stepped up an
exceptional way it ended up being about
99 of workers getting vaccinated and
i
it's my belief
strong belief that everyone should get
vaccinated there's some new
opportunities and noblevax produces
provides a new opportunity now i would
note that you're about 30 times likely
30 times more likely to be in critical
care if you're unvaccinated in bc today
with all of this
and
it is
absolutely i think
necessary for people who who are ready
for their booster dose to get their
booster dose if you're interested in
novavax that's 1-833-838-2323
you can go on the list and we'll contact
you and make arrangements for that and
if you're a parent of a child 5 to 11
there are opportunities all over bc for
your child to be vaccinated as well this
is a crucial part of our response in
terms of our briefings yes this will be
the last and what you call
regular briefings but
as dr henry has said i i would expect in
the in the week of march 31st you'll be
seeing uh
uh seeing dr henry myself again from dr
henry probably some modeling to show
where we are in the pandemic at that
point and uh we'll continue of course to
be available on a regular basis to
respond to questions about this and and
many other subjects
next question comes from lisa cardasco
vancouver's son
thank you um i'm wondering why you
decided that masks are no longer needed
in schools or won't be soon
when most children under the age of 11
are not fully vaccinated and
along with that can you expand on what
you are contemplating regarding the k-12
and child care guidelines
yeah so
we
we know that schools are very
structured environment with the same uh
children that go in and out in the
classrooms um
in the child care settings
similar things so we know that as risk
goes down in the community that's
reflected in risk in these structured
lower risk environments in schools so it
absolutely will will be a mass positive
environment and those who continue to
want to wear masks and are comfortable
doing that will be supported to do that
both staff and students but it will no
longer be a mandate in classrooms in
particular and in other parts of the of
the school so
the education
we've been working with our education
partners to revise those guidelines
they'll also include things around
there's been limits on
people who can come in and out of the
school on some of the additional
measures we put in place for omicron
around staggering of breaks and things
like that that will no longer be needed
when we get to that point at the end of
spring break and it's a time of
transition to help support children to
getting back to a more
next normal i'm hearing it called
but a more
normal environment to support them in
the development and growth and all of
the other important things
around the schools
that support
young children in particular so it is
trying to balance what's needed to
protect kids and mitigate those risks
and ensure that we can
allow them to get the most out of the
school environment
lisa do you have a follow-up
yes thank you
going forward the surveillance program
you'll be relying on the sentinel
program
which will pick up the sickest of people
um and the wastewater which you know
captures the lower mainland only but
meanwhile in the interior and northern
health cases remain
to be raging um so
wondering then you know we're not going
to be doing surveillance through pcr
testing of anyone who has coveted
symptoms so
i'm wondering
what assurances you can give to british
columbians who might not be confident
that you will be able to pick up early
warning signals
yeah so i mean those are some of the
things that we
report but there are many other
surveillance streams that we watch
on a daily basis and a weekly basis to
help us understand what's going on in
different communities around the
province so it's uh i've likened it in
in many ways to to a puzzle where
there's different pieces that come from
different places so if we see a signal
in one thing so wastewater is up for one
reason and
we've done some in
a university residence and we saw a
spike and then we say okay well what's
happening why do we see a spike in this
so there's a whole number of different
places that we watch so we look at
outbreaks in long-term care we look at
what's happening in our hospitals we
have testing programs for workers in
certain situations that we
continue to monitor so it's not
only
one thing or another and pcr testing
will continue it'll continue we have
sentinel physician testing
right now we've been using a lot of the
testing centers but that will transition
as we would for any respiratory illness
so if you're sick enough to need medical
care you can get a test from your
physician and that will tell whether
it's
we have a
multiplex array testing that
is done in emergency departments it's
done in
in
healthcare said in
your physician's office for example that
tests for influenza and para influenza
and rsv and covet so
those are the things that we have in
place for other respiratory illnesses
that will continue
to allow us to
to monitor in a systematic way what
we're seeing
for for sars co v2 as well so i would
encourage you to look at for example our
influenza surveillance report that comes
out weekly those are some of the
measures that we will integrate uh
coveted surveillance into
next question comes from cole schissler
black press
hi there thanks for taking my question
uh you said that this will be a
uncomfortable time for folks who are
susceptible to severe outcomes to colvin
but for people at high risk it's not a
matter of comfort for them it's a matter
of life and death
with restrictions being lifted what what
is in place to protect people at high
risk and what will the problem do to
support those people
yeah so we need to recognize that the
things that are in place that are making
it
less risky for all of us
are vaccination and that the fact that
we've all been vaccinated for ourselves
protects others too so that's the really
big one and that's why we're in this
place that we're in we have that level
of immunity but we also know that people
who are going through cancer treatments
people who have transplants they have
always had to take additional
protections to ensure that they're not
exposed to respiratory illnesses and to
other infectious diseases because they
know their immune systems are not as
strong so we will continue to be able to
provide them the support that they need
and this is what you know we're trying
to say today that it is important for us
to all recognize that we don't know
everybody's story and there's a reason
why somebody may be wearing a mask
there's a reason why somebody may be
asking us to wear a mask if we're coming
to visit them or to have a test before
we go into long-term care because those
are things that help us
support those people whose immune
systems no matter how many vaccines they
have are not going to be able to fully
protect them and they may be more at
risk so it is about
us all recognizing that those people are
part of our social networks part of our
families part of our workplaces and that
the measures that we're taking are
respectful and supportive to make sure
that they're protected as well
cole do you have a follow-up
yeah with
you know more people dropping the mass
with the vaccine card requirement going
away
hopefully kobe doesn't go back up
but if it does
are we going to see increased testing to
detect long coved in people and is the
province going to or does the province
have a plan to step up supports for
people who are suffering from long covet
yeah long covet is one of those things
that
is related to infections we also know
that some of the key measures that help
prevent long covet are vaccination your
risk is dramatically decreased if you're
immunized and you happen to have a
breakthrough infection
so
we there's also many things we don't yet
know about long-term effects of covid
and some of them where we're starting to
learn um about the effects on the brain
about the effects on
other
parts of our our systems over time
[Music]
and those will continue there will
continue to be
supports in place we have as you know a
clinic
for clinics and
it's a hub and spoke model to support
people getting
assessed through their family physician
or through their local community clinic
and they can
get into that but i think we also need
to i'm not making a whole lot of sense
but yes
those are important considerations
really important considerations and
globally we're trying to understand the
longer term impacts some of which we
won't know for years from now i don't
know if you want to add to that yet
absolutely and i just add to this and
this is
you know
i think we've seen
in
recent weeks with the
invasion of ukraine
how
issues and
terrible actions by
people in this case the russian
president affect people all around the
world
with respect to covet 19 it's important
to remember
and dr henry has made this point
repeatedly and survived
that we continue to have to work
to vaccinate people throughout the world
around the world in every part of the
world
i mean we have to learn surely a
fundamental lesson of the coven 19
pandemic in our modern world is that
events that happen
and viruses that emerge somewhere well
across the world can affect us here
we refer to variants
and sometimes by the origin
where they were discovered it's not
where they started but where they were
discovered such as
um
such as
the omnicron variant of concern itself
which was discovered by outstanding
scientists in south africa
but we have an obligation as a world
to
not just fully vaccinate ourselves in bc
and we're going to continue to do that
and the effort continues to do that and
i think it's a very strong one here and
the fact that we're getting on to 94
percent of adults that are vaccinated is
pretty impressive in bc but we have to
see that happen throughout the world
because that is
part of the response to in this period
to both the omicron variant of concern
in the future of covet 19. so it it
matters in bc
um that there is
a vaccination in south africa
and it matters
and it matters in bc that there's
vaccination
in all countries in the world and we
have to continue to support those
measures at a national and international
level to ensure that everyone has the
right that everyone in bc has had
to a
free available
uh vaccine that makes them safer
just one other comment about it you know
it's it from the very beginning we know
that there are
um there there are balancing that we
need to do and we need to balance the
measures that are put in place with the
impacts that they can have sometimes
positive but also negative so we are at
a place where we're in the balancing the
risk of covid and mitigating it
with measures that are less restrictive
so that we can support people in the
recovery from what we've been through in
this last
in this last two years so we know that
there's been dramatic impacts on young
people in schools in post-secondary
institutions on anxiety on mental health
and so finding this balance is really
important
ensuring that we can start focusing on
getting back to some of the the things
that are really important around
connecting around
being able to
sing together without masks on in a safe
environment and doing that to support
people to recover from what we've been
through as well as trying to minimize
the transmission of covet over the next
little while
we have time for one more question today
we'll go to belle pury cbc
dr henry
you have repeatedly said that you know
we can't let our guard down because who
knows what's coming so i'm wondering
what work is being done
right now while the case counts and
transmissions are low to
prepare for what might be coming in the
fall you know and especially in our
health care system and in the education
system and if we could get an answer in
english and french please
yeah you know i've talked a little bit
about how we need to manage this is one
of the serious respiratory illnesses
that's going to be with us for time for
some time and we're still in the place
where we're learning about covid and
it's still changing so we're not yet in
that endemic state where we know what to
expect so
part of what we're doing is is focusing
on surveillance and integrating it into
the things that we do to monitor for
other serious respiratory illnesses we
need to focus on on the impact on our
health care system and i know the
minister and deputy
steve brown have been very seized with
how do we build up our health human
resources how do we
ensure that we have the nurses and
physicians and others who are healthy
and and
have recovered from this pandemic enough
to support us as we get through the next
uh phase of of this pandemic the
transition phase and we need to look at
what we've learned we've learned about
the importance of vaccination and
vaccine preventable diseases we've
learned at the importance of different
tools we've learned about the importance
of ventilation in buildings both in
workplaces in healthcare in schools so
those are things that we need to think
about we need to think about
how we have better access to testing
better tests better vaccines better
treatments so those are all things that
we need to focus on and we need to look
at as well how do we support
behaviors we've learned things about
what it means to wear mass in certain
settings and how some people react to
that and what some of the downside
impacts are so how do we make that
behavior
supportive and
um empowering for people to protect
themselves as we go into another
piece of uncertainty
the other thing i think is really
important is some of the things we've
learned about
how to support
workers in long-term care in our
long-term care sector that was so
fragmented and didn't have
you know the single site order so how do
we transition that into a supportive
positive working environment for people
in long-term care how do we
the things around sick leave and how
that is such an important tool to allow
people to take those measures to stay
away from others if they're sick
themselves so i think there's lots of
things that we need to think about about
what we've learned from this pandemic to
take us through um next year and you
know the other thing i'm very passionate
about is
this pandemic
pandemic has exposed some of the
inequities
in our society and so how do we use this
opportunity to start addressing some of
those
and
and just say in english one of the
reasons when we
first delayed surgeries
in the spring of 2020
in that time in the middle of march
through to the end of may
we made a commitment to
to catch up and we did more than 99 of
those surgeries that were delayed
completed and we ended up in the
calendar year that followed it doing
more surgeries than we've done the
previous year in spite of the fact that
covid19
caused consumed time the precautions
that are required for covert 19 actually
made surgeries longer we did it by
adding hours at the end of days we did
it by adding surgeries on weekends we
did it by 81 measures that were taken
across health authorities to increase
the number of surgeries and to reduce
wait times such that there are fewer
people waiting for surgeries today than
they were at the beginning of the
pandemic
and we have to take those steps in every
area and a critical one is health human
resources making sure that we have the
doctors and nurses the health sciences
professionals the healthcare workers we
need and lots of the measures we've
taken in the pandemic have had an impact
on that the wage leveling component of
the single site initiative for example
the hcap program that's brought
thousands of new workers to long-term
care the steps we're taking to expand
nursing spaces
all of the steps we're taking the steps
that we continue to do to to make it
easier for internationally educated
healthcare workers to come and to to be
in bc and to use their skills to the
full extent
of their ability all of these things are
important
the final thing i wanted to note is that
prior to the pandemic we had seen
a decline in overdose deaths in our
public health emergency that's the
overdose crisis that has so focused our
efforts for
the last now
more than five years and that continues
to be a challenge we come through the
pandemic and some of the actions taken
during the pandemic including the fact
that people were spending more time
alone impacted
the outcomes
of overdoses and led to overdose deaths
and so we have a continuing obligation
as a health care system and as a society
to address both public health
emergencies it continues today it
doesn't stop we need to be relentless
and we will be
bell do you have a follow-up
i do and uh i have to remind the
minister to answer the first question in
french when he comes up again please in
the meantime dr henry um when you talked
about changes to visitation rules and
long-term care uh you suggested that it
it won't be immediate can you give
people
who really want to get in there to see
their family members a timeline of when
they can expect all facilities to come
into compliance with the updated rules
yeah so we've been talking with the
sector over the last couple of days
around this and so it will be by next
friday so we're giving a week
some people will be some facilities will
be ready tomorrow others it may take a
little bit longer to ramp up
their ability to to cope with uh larger
numbers of visitors coming in but the
expectation is that it will be by
by next friday the 18th
we apologize
[Music]
we're going to leave it there for now so
a big day in bc you're watching bc1 and
in breaking news this afternoon the
province announcing some major major
shifts
when it comes to bc's covid19
restrictions saying that from this
friday
you will no longer have to wear a mask
in an indoor public space
i'm going to bring in keith baldry to
break down what today's announcement
means for you here in british columbia
keith good to see you um a lot to break
down let's just recap
the math mandate first of all where will
people be able to walk around mask free
from friday and what is the science
behind this decision dr henry is giving
today
yeah so her the science was presented
before the announcement was made which
is chart after chart after chart showing
the trend lines when it comes to
hospitalizations vaccinations deaths
icu cases and such uh the lines have
been trending the right way the arrows
have been pointing the right way for
weeks now so it's all pointing
converging on a point which starts
tomorrow with lifting one order which is
the mandatory mass requirement in indoor
public spaces uh that ceases to exist as
of one minute after midnight tonight uh
also the vaccine passport requirement to
get into restaurants and other venues
expires
on april 8 friday april 8. those are the
two biggies announced today
but there's some staggered starts as
well on other measures long-term care
homes now or going back to unlimited
visitors but requiring vaccination uh
passports there and mask wearing in
those long-term care settings also
healthcare will be continue to be a
place where you have to wear a mask and
where you have to be vaccinated if you
want to work in the health care system
in acute care settings but what's
interesting she's leaving it up to
employers on various
situations notably translink nbc transit
to decide if they want to have a mass
mandate within their workplace that's
still an option uh there at the hands of
uh of individual workplaces i don't i
don't okay so that will require mass but
some will have
everyone will have the option to keep it
in place all right so just to recap just
to explain this in terms of workplaces
it'll be their choice if they want to
keep their mask policy in place
but in indoor public spaces so we're
talking you know the mall um uh the
shops grocery stores where else i'm i'm
thinking of you know cinemas i guess
like theaters those are those those are
the main areas when yeah where do people
congregate indoors shopping malls is the
classic example yeah also no no masks
required there as of just one minute
after midnight tonight all right i'm
going to bring in richard zusman who
also joins us he's been watching this
all
from the room where dr henry and adrian
dix have been speaking just uh a short
time ago
richard the the mask policy um
just talk to us about schools a lot of
people watching who have kids in school
does this change anything for those
children who have to mask up right now
yeah not immediately sonia but after
spring break kids will no longer be
required to wear masks in k-12 i just
got a text message from a teacher
highly concerned here the bctf has
already sent out a tweet saying they
would like to see a delay by a week in
terms of implementation to give the
school system some time to understand
this transition
it will still be considered schools will
be a mask safe zone a mass positive zone
is the word that dr bonnie henry used an
encouragement for kids to continue to
wear their masks inside the school
system but it will not be required by
provincial health and like all of these
changes and i'm sure keith alluded to it
is these are based on the guidance that
we have seen but also the data that we
have seen here to show that it's still
important to wear masks to get
vaccinated to wash our hands to stay
home when we're sick but it is no longer
government's purview to require
people to wear masks right for the
school system there's a full review
going on right now sonia into the
guidelines but for masking those will be
gone after spring break and that date
will change uh depending on when your
kids are in spring break across the
province and i'm just going to stay with
you for a minute because you did ask dr
henry the question about uh those that
are immune compromised and how you know
it's a big section of of people that are
going to feel very uncomfortable and
very at risk now with the mask mandate
being taken away from friday so what did
you make of how she answered that
yeah so i still think there is going to
be a part of this population who is
incredibly distressed around these
changes we have lived our lives a
certain way for two years and these
changes will be jarring but dr henry
made it clear those places where we wear
our masks right now where it's required
are not the places we see the high rates
of transmission and so at the grocery
store or the pharmacy or those other
essential places people need to go
that's not where we have seen
transmission but still
individual businesses can impose mass
mandates that could include places like
transit although based on dr henry's
responses today it would be surprising
if transit moved forward with a mask
mandate themselves i would expect just
that encouragement for people to wear
their own mask keep your distance when
you can
and then stay away if you are sick but
there is going to be a lot of concern
from those who are immunocompromised the
other last point here sonia those who
have cancer are in the midst of
treatments and are immunocompromised
already need to make different decisions
every respiratory flu season and dr
henry basically said right now is no
different than that uh when it comes to
those precautions okay i'm gonna go back
to keith uh you've you mentioned briefly
uh changes to the vaccine passport so
let's just break that down in a bit more
detail for people watching um there's a
set date now from when we will not have
to use a vaccine passport to get into
places
yeah that's friday april 8th uh
inadvertently reported april 9th on the
new news i was out one day but yeah
friday april 8 no longer
needing requirement of vaccination proof
to get into restaurants and other venues
that currently require a vaccination
proof of vaccination
but the fact is that's not really going
to affect a lot of people because the
vast majority of british columbians have
vaccination cards so it's not an issue
for them uh the people who will be
affected by this will be the people who
are unvaccinated that's a relatively
small number of people in bc well it's a
small percentage of that i was going to
say when you say it's a small percentage
what's the number
it's about seven percent who are here to
get a single dose uh so it's uh again
seven
percent sounds like a very small number
when you translate it to the number of
people who have not been vaccinated no
we're talking more than 300 000 people
over the age of 12 have yet to get a
single dose and then you've got about a
hundred thousand kids age five to eleven
who have yet to get a single dose so a
small percentage of people don't have
vaccine cards the vast majority of the
population do so that's not as big a
deal i think for
most people than the dropping the
mandatory mask rule that's that's going
to affect far more far more people
dropping the vaccine card rule but those
people that are not vaccinated and
there's like several hundred thousand
that you just mentioned there from april
8th
they won't have any problems getting
into these places like restaurants and
stuff
unless a a restaurant wants to put
in case in place their own safety rule
and any business can do that right now
you can have your own safety rule for
your workers and for your customers you
can't go into a restaurant and sit down
if you don't wear any shoes or don't
have a shirt no shoes no shirt no
service
do you not think that's going to be a
bit slightly different with this though
can you imagine uh so the province says
you don't have to use a vaccine card and
a restaurant comes down and says you
know you still have to show it at the
door i i have no idea i have no idea
yeah that's that's just an option
restaurants restaurants businesses
restaurants
yeah go on richard
yeah and
and they can make the decisions on if
they believe that that's what their
customers want their workplaces and
that's what they can do and
they are going to try to create an
environment that is safe for their
workers and safe for their customers do
you think that's going to lead to
problems though in this province
well right now we're dealing
with a very quick and changing situation
and no doubt sonia there could be
protests there could be frustrations
businesses will weigh all of these
things i would not expect somewhere like
saveon
to keep the mask mandate in place a big
large grocery chain but you could have a
small community grocer keep it in place
i wouldn't expect a big chain like
cactus club to have a vaccine card but
you could have a corner mom-and-pop shop
that decides that they're going to keep
the vaccine card yes they could be
bringing on protests for their employees
and for their customers and they will be
acutely aware of that but these are
decisions that every business will make
based on how they're going to both treat
their customers and treat their
employees as well all right um just and
finally uh just a couple more things so
no changes to who can go and visit a
loved one in a care home uh all those
restrictions have pretty much been
lifted now keith and places of worship
uh back to
how they were pre-pandemic is that
correct yeah so
in terms of long-term care that rule
takes effect a week friday march 18th is
when the the lifting of limits on
visitors uh to long-term care homes so
now you can the whole family visit
grandma or grandpa our loved one in the
long-term care home there still is going
to be
a mass requirement and a
health protocol just as health protocols
aren't changing in health care settings
so again the the big change in long-term
care is the number of people who are
going to be able to go visit a loved one
it's been one or two and that's been not
uniformly applied across the system some
kind of homes have been applying rules
differently but now they're being told
to open up in terms of visitors to have
many more people that have been seeing
loved ones and again that starts a week
friday okay um we've also been told that
uh both dicks and henry get a couple of
weeks off we're gonna see less of them
it's almost like it's over but it's not
really over um i'm just seeing on
twitter there's already been a
reaction from bc green leaders sonya
first know who is very critical of
the mask mandate being lifted everywhere
she said she would have liked to have
seen that stay in transit and certain
essential services and also criticizing
the government for not being transparent
when making these decisions and
if you can just pick up on that richard
yeah so part of this is the data that
some want to see doesn't exist anymore
it's much harder to track what we're
seeing in transmission and largely this
is based on what we're seeing in
wastewater as well as trend lines and
the determination was made here that it
doesn't mean that masks aren't important
they just no longer need to be mandated
by government i will still be wearing my
mask when i am out in public for weeks
and likely even longer and dr henry said
she would do the same premier horgan has
told me he's going to do the same i'm
guessing based on what i know about
keith he's probably going to do the same
too these are decisions that people will
have to make it's about changing the
burden of responsibility
we are going to hear concerns like sonia
first knows from a lot of people but the
consensus here is that there was a sense
we were ready to move on here okay
public health data shows that it is time
to move on just before i let you both
move on um just update us on what we're
hearing about uh a large a very large uh
protest convoy that is going to be
moving into victoria by the sounds of it
for quite some time keith
well we'll see i've talked to uh
minister farnworth about this premier
horgan about this there is concern about
this no question but there's also hope
that today's announcement sort of takes
the air out of the balloon uh the
concern is though that this is not a
protest necessarily about vaccines or
anything this is a giant political
protest that touches on all sorts of
issues it'll be interesting to see
whether there's any preemptive court
action taken here i note it was
reminding me yesterday on the door and
on the windows or right around the
legislature remain the copies of the
injunction that was granted here
preventing
barring anyone from blocking access to
this building i've talked to one lawyer
and former politician points out that
could be interpreted as not allowing
people to block entrance into the bc
legislature from the road which means
the truck convoy
might be challenged on that basis but
there's a bit of nervousness about this
no question but there's also the hope
that today's announcement stands this
group down and they're not going to go
to all the trouble of getting on a bc
ferry and coming over here uh yeah
especially when you think what will they
actually be protesting now um all right
thanks very much both of you brilliant
to talk to you as always